[Musique]
c'est une société qui est née aux
États-Unis à Boston et dont le but
premier était de donner la possibilité à
des start-up de biotechnologie d'accéder
à des locaux des laboratoires tout
équipés et d'avoir accès également au
service qui vient avec afin de pouvoir
leur permettre de se focaliser sur le
développement de leur science nous avons
une offre qui est vraiment dédiée aux
sociétés des sciences de vivant en leur
offrant à la fois des espaces de
laboratoire qu'ils soient commun ou
privés et des espaces tertiaires encore
une fois qu'ils soient commun ou privés
en plus de cette offre relativement
innovante nous amenons un service qui
est complet un service qui va
correspondre par exemple à la gestion
des laboratoires à la formation des
techniciens à l'utilisation de certains
équipements au respect des règles de
biosécurité puisque nous avons des
laboratoires de confinement L1 et L2
mais également à la création de ce que
l'on appelle la communauté donc essayer
de mettre en oeuvre un réseau le réseau
des entrepreneurs de biotechnologie au
niveau local au niveau national européen
évidemment avec nos partenaires
américains au niveau global l'idée c'est
que cette communauté puisse s'enrichir
d'elle-même au travers des différentes
expériences qu'elle a vécues mais
également accéder à des fonds puisque
c'est le nerf de la guerre en
biotechnologie et pour arriver à lever
ses fonds il faut démontrer que l'on
sait dérisqué la phase la plus
dangereuse dans le développement d'un
médicament ou d'un service c'est la
phase de R&D et c'est exactement ce que
nous amenons une accélération du time to
market à ses entreprises en faisant en
sorte de dérisquer tout ce qui est phase
de R&D puisque ils n'ont pas besoin
d'acheter des locaux du matériel ou
d'embaucher des responsables hygiène et
sécurité par exemple alors le choix qu'a
fait servié en venant installer
l'ensemble de ces centres rédés sur le
territoire Paris-Saclay n'est pas anodin
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer on va y
trouver l'ensemble des
ce qu'on qualifie de dur qui sont
aujourd'hui tout à fait nécessaires
notamment en informatique en bio
informatique en ingénierie également
pour tout ce qui est médical device et
on est surtout dans une phase
d'ébullition en termes d'innovation et
je crois que un acteur de la pharmacie
comme Servier était absolument utile
pour assurer la complétude en terme de
compétences du plateau de sacrée et ce
dynamisme la richesse de ses étudiants
et ses entrepreneurs fait que installer
un incubateur biotech sur ce territoire
là a tout à fait son sens ce que nous
souhaitons c'est cristalliser vraiment
cet univers de l'élévation en biais
technologique sur le plateau de Saclay
au travers de l'existence de spartners
by Servian bye nous organisons très
régulièrement des visites et des
présentations de cette incubateur qui
ouvrira à l'horizon du 1er juin nous
avons déjà sélectionné deux entreprises
d'ici le mois de avril deux nouvelles
seront sélectionnés et ainsi de suite
tous les mois ou tous les deux mois donc
n'hésitez pas à prendre contact pour ne
serait-ce qu'avoir une petite vision de
ce que peut offrir ce Partners et nous
vous présenterons avec plaisir nos
différents sites